principio de entendimiento para un único
objetivo dar salida a la crisis de
venezuela este viernes arrancaron en
ciudad de mexico las conversaciones
entre gobierno y oposición venezolana
auspiciadas por noruega con el
acompañamiento de rusia y países bajos
vislumbramos
el trabajadora es buscar en donde
encontramos punto de confluencia para
garantizar el porvenir y la felicidad
del pueblo del psoe derechos políticos
garantías y hoja de ruta electoral fin
de las sanciones económicas respeto al
estado constitucional renuncia a la
violencia protección social y garantías
de verificación de lo acordado son los
siete puntos de un documento que busca
llegar a un acuerdo integral de
convivencia democrática todo bajo una
metodología basada en el principio que
nada está acordado hasta que todo lo
esté el acercamiento representa un gran
paso para ambos actores que no se
sentaban desde 2019 cuando fracasaron
las conversaciones en barbados
ha tenido que ver
es una gráfica para lograr un promedio
de inicio
teniendo la convicción de que el
proyecto es más que necesario
no asistió al acto nicolás maduro ni
tampoco juan guaidó quien tras
proclamarse presidente interino del país
en 2019 fue reconocido por 60 países de
los que ahora quedan sólo 10 según el
winston center la unión europea se
desmarcó del reconocimiento agua ido a
principios de este año eeuu sigue
apoyando al líder opositor y bloquea la
economía petrolera del país a través de
sanciones que tanto gobierno como
oposición coinciden en que deben ser
levantadas la administración de joe
biden se ha mostrado dispuesta a revisar
su política si hay avances
significativos en estos diálogos